okay that was a slow start I was
connected to the wrong Network so I
reconnected and I lost about the minimum
on the clock
but okay I'm playing at 12:45
so time odds shouldn't be too much of a
problem and we have a Budapest I'm gonna
win back the pawn on e5 and try and go
for some some quick initiative somehow
someway let's take with this night
slightly more aggressive mmm he's really
tempting me I really want to take a pawn
on f2 or on e3 not much time to think
nothing seems to work actually let's
take on actually taking on e3 with the
bishop no that's all too hopeful let's
just take on that three with Chuck and
then I'll move back to f6 okay and hello
to people in the chats
hello ex villager hello to Ben Paul
thurston hello super major pain and
Xander meise n' i should pick up the
pace because i lost a lot of time due to
this stream setup I'll put the knight on
e4 and then go for this rook lift rook
a6 to g6 is very typical in the budapest
Knight g3 looks attractive might take
off two looks let's find I take F to
probably not sound but okay the rook is
pinned the very worst all when the rook
can have rook into ponds for
minor pieces best-case scenario I just
keep the rook pinned and apply pressure
the Queen h4 now is king and queen are
tied down to defining the rook and I'll
stick my queen in g3 you can't really
remove the Queen now maybe I have some
plan of taking on each three looks okay
okay so that's a good move
it's a very good move I think now I have
to take and he's playing well for his
rating I played some unsound moves
getting slightly punished
he plays Bishop d3 I'll take on Eve one
I have to play like Queenie six if he
takes on e1 so at least I'm not getting
mated this would be a good move that he
missed it let's play h6 he could have
taken on each seven and if I take back
Knight g5 would be a fork so okay how
the goal is to flag him his White's
better here White has two minors
actually maybe it's no that's not good
for black the White has some attack but
okay my rook will come to e8 my bishop
will come to c6 I'm now up on time and
the attack isn't too menacing
and this is just three plus zero so
there's no no added time which is quite
helpful
I think I can be quite confident that
he's gonna flag here and also lose a
material okay oh let's just play moves
okay
won the first game so I was honestly not
planning on streaming but I needed a
break from work I just got back from
cafe where I didn't have an outlet I got
there my computer was full on charge
I had like a large peppermint latte and
now I'm highly cut highly caffeinated
may not feel like it but I am and I just
needed a break from doing work so now
I'm here
and go back to tournaments now that he
played well for being rated 12:45 how
high of a rating can someone who starts
playing chess seriously gets it depends
how serious you are and when you start
younger players tend to have more
potential than older players because
justice is very similar to learning a
language it gets easier to learn when
you're younger what's still possible to
get good and even if you're older just
have to put in work and be disciplined
until the line this properly looks nice
okay someone mentioning the saffir
gambits which I'll try and play I'm
still in the process of recording a
course which will be release hopefully
hopefully by the end of this month maybe
next month have more information on it
when it comes out a3 I think I can take
and maybe even try and win a pawn I mean
we could just be trading everything but
a3 wasn't that useful now it feels like
I have the extra tempo
trying to figure out how I'm getting
some advantage here I mean I could take
with the B pond and balance things a
little bit then like Queen f6 maybe or
just defend this pawn okay so box up
upon I'll play Bishop f5 how do I get
better at chess that's a kind of generic
question but I'll try and answer that
question I'll try and answer that
question in like an extended blog
article or video because I get that
question so often I just want to like
have a have some piece of content to
point people towards I don't want to
trade but I might have to play Knight g5
if he wants to take it he can take it
I play the modern defense with g3 sorry
g6 you don't have to be sorry
but yeah I can try and play modern next
game if I'm black
if I remember c2 his attacks the bishops
pinned mine Queen has now attacked let's
play Queen e4 keep the pressure that was
a sound sound was that Kover $20 I can't
see your message Congrats on I think
that side Congrats on 10k youtube subs
thanks Kover really appreciate that came
out of nowhere
covert I'm trying to remember where
you're from I feel like you're from
Australia but I could be wrong pretty
sure it's Australia though okay this is
a free pawn and let's go back what does
a good rating for hobby player depends
what level of hobby your
talking about I mean like this hobby
mean playing in tournaments and do the
ratings refer to tournament rating or
online rating in these days it's
possible to get good quite quickly with
the online resources but you have to
devote yourself you have to spend time
doing tactics doing more instructional
things rather than just playing blitz or
bullets
okay so I have two extra pawns the Tri
Nguyen the g5 Phan it's a little bit
weak and whites a little bit tied down
to be - okay no longer tied down to be -
because the b2 pawn has vanished I guess
I'll take and then I'll activate the
rook this way going for rip g4 or rook
take d4 so I'm just winning an absurd
number of pawns we could trade rooks but
I'll just okay now I'm okay with a rook
trade let's activate the King how we can
trade rooks and then I'll start pushing
pawns or winning pawns and then pushing
pawns and defending pawns and locating
pawns
okay white resigns GG peppermint latte
yeah I have a latte I wanted caffeine
it's a very cheap productivity half
maybe not the most healthy pack but I'm
more productive when I'm caffeinated
it's a sad sad truth fish nine okay so
I'm playing some lower rated players and
they're trying to win more quickly than
the previous two games and now we have a
Safford gambit this is a the golden
position in the Stafford and he just
fell for one of my favorite drops
because now Locke wins a queen and life
is good life is better
life is best
okay packed a tournament was a great
game
that's why staffer gambit it's such a
good opening like these people they play
natural moves and then they follow parts
okay now I'm playing a slightly higher
rated player compared to my last few
opponents play a Grand Prix with Bishop
to b5 nine AB six trying to remember
I'll play the four Knights with like
Bishop b5 because a6 I don't think is a
great move because I wanted to take
anyway but now maybe even a five and
I'll bring my Knight to e4 attacking
upon and let's start with d3 conserving
c4 but the night before d3 is weak I'm
just gonna play h3 want to restrict this
Bishop and Castle though he wants to
play Queen c7 let's start with Queen e2
if Queen c7 I might have some fancy
Knight d6 move now the plan is just to
play it additional and also play quicker
I'll start with b3 preparing Bishop b2
so this pawn is supported ready to play
rook d1 I probably just want to play c4
and then Rick do you want kick the night
away
okay so he wants to play a four so I'll
play a for myself now before is more of
an outpost for black but shouldn't be a
problem
neither for I completely forgot about
let's do this g5 unexpected let's start
with rook t1 probably put the other
ricany one and then just kind of be
patient he kind of wants to sac on each
three though is that dangerous maybe
it's kind of dangerous
I'll prevent him from sacking by sacking
myself
they take g5 defending h3 maybe a whole
sack anyway on h3 I have to see if he
doesn't then he moves the knight so I'll
play if 95 I'll play f4 have some have
some attack there's some positional
compensation kind of woo he sacks okay
things are getting complicated
I think I will sack the rook this game
is turning into a battle of who can sack
more so if he takes the rook I'll be
down the exchange if he plays queen g4
it's somehow equal material I'm not sure
how that happened
Bishop h6 I have to play off four then
I'll have rook g2 ideas that six is
probably a good move let's play Knight
e4
and what to do you want some play Bishop
h6 and drop the rook yeah the rook is
kind of stuck I have to move much
quicker to its only move I saw not the
prettiest move though it creates a very
glaring weakness but I have to roll with
the punches b5 is kind of a target
maybe rook here and I'll start
pressuring e5
mmm interesting but I can take my
bishops defended but my rook is kind of
overworked so maybe he'll just win upon
I'm gonna win mmm he wins t3 immediately
well-played okay so I'm down on time I
have a terrible position but I have hope
I'm gonna do this first voiding backing
stuff and then maybe rookie three soon
and he's nervous can tell by the amount
of time that he's using me fives week
yeah he's really nervous he's probably
just like shaking I'm just freezing up
okay let's topple up
nice thing is each one is always
defended by the night let's play I don't
know what to play I'll just make a move
until he flags
yeah at night h1 this is so clutch
now e4 is weak
okay I take with check very importance
mm maybe back with check and then I'll
activate the rook and black is fogging
okay not the best quality game but a
game nonetheless okay what are people
saying just add blue in the chats the
loan mod way not the loan mod because we
have ax villager too but ax village
you're leaving for school but it's after
midnight but he's probably in Norway so
that makes sense should be stream labs
as a banner below stream wait what oh
how can I donate there should be a
donate command but I don't know
Jimmy Ackerman welcome back can you have
one the bishop at the end with Bishop g5
check wait what
Oh Knight g5 check yes that's a move
that I missed I was so focused on
defending I figure out about attacking
what time control is good for a practice
not the time control that I'm playing
unless you want to practice blitz but I
mean to practice your overall chest
probably at least 10 minutes or more
Alex see I'll welcome the first time
nice there's any other first time people
here let me know back two tournaments 53
minutes left I could try and make a
running for first place I was not really
intending to play the whole tournaments
but maybe it'll happen so vpg 17 connor
monday wake honor Monday it just turned
to Monday it's midnight
Wow happy Monday do I want a bezerk no
let's play normal let's play a London
ooh Dutch let's play a London anyway
and the philosophy of Dutch or of London
versus Dutch is white will play more
ambitiously with c4 and very key move
coming up after castling pawn c5 and
this is an interesting line white wants
to open this diagonal get in Bishop c4
check maybe provoke d5 so I can explain
5h4 is a common move h6 is reasonable
let's play Queen b3 target east 6 I want
to provoke d5 and then XY e 5 Queen e7
so he's being reasonable mmm
it's just play with t1 keeping some
tension not entirely sure what's going
on thinking about d5 here but then e 5
[Music]
maybe I can play like Knight d2 it looks
passive but let's do it it might be a
pawn sack like you could take on c3 and
then take on c5 but then if I was very
weak he wants to play Knight a5 some d5
no Knight a5 so probably Queen a3 is
typical apply pressure and threatening
to win a pawn if he takes I probably
play 95 and go for 'if I've Exploitation
d5 interesting so he wants to play Jade
oh no he wants to play next now it just
seems Pleasant like this is what I was
kind of hoping for I guess maybe he has
long-term ideas of 'if I've i have
long-term ideas of ship take Knights
yeah
let's play this at least attack that and
then a cheat to see to retreat to be -
sometimes you have to retreat before you
can win oh I want to put my king on g1
he's gonna play like Bishop a6 maybe or
that okay let's put the King on g1
the bishop on f4
interesting I don't think I want to
trade Bishop's the reason for putting my
king on g1 and not casting is my rook
wants to stay on the H file let's take
but the bishop on b3 I'm happy he took
with pawn because now the files closed
my queen is safe from the rook that move
was completely unexpected but maybe it's
just a trade because I went age six and
you have to start moving quicker maybe
rook b1 coming East six will be a target
as well okay let's take and then play
Knight g5 live King off six nine h7
he'll go for f4 discouraging e5
preparing King F to controlling e5
rookie - I guess it's gonna play rook b5
probably do do I have this move this
move attacks a knight and pins a knight
I think this just wins material that's
nice and you can't even like give away
the exchange because the knight and the
rook are both undefended this is very
nice so he just resigns I don't watch
The Big Bang Theory so I don't know who
Sheldon is I've been compared to like so
many different people though I have a
list of people that I've been compared
to so I'll have to have to add Sheldon
to the list and maybe look up some
episode yeah that was a weird game some
we word opening a very tense position
I completely forgot about Queen takes e5
this pawn being pinned on d4 but it
wasn't that bad and then yeah round here
I liked like the position and this
maneuver with Bishop e2 to h5 was just
bad I missed a even missed Bishop a4
right away okay back to tournaments 11th
place 16 points
so I'm eight points away from the lead I
could maybe start buzzer King maybe if I
play some lower rated players I'm not
like accepting challenges right now
okay I'll beserk and I'll play you for I
just have to remember I desert and I'll
play quickly
hey it's some bits
thanks for the bits gray Hatter Danish
gambit it's hard to play the Danish
gambit against the Cairo common 97 I'm
trying to remember this line I think
this and then 95 oops I dropped my queen
no he didn't take it I think this is
reasonable I just have to move more
quickly i blundered upon no don't play
queen 85 okay he didn't see Queen a 5
that's good now I have a pleasant
position bishop pair relatively open
open D file and half open e-file I can
live with this
ooh g3 runs into the ship g4 and the
rook is trapped so always played this at
f1 and always play King b1 then Feingold
would be so happy with me right now I'm
gonna play okay let's play c4
I wanna play g3 and Bishop back to d3
kit Bishop e3 this is the targets
hmm probably want to play rookie d1 and
then like rook d6 and move quickly
maybe Bishop t3i does this winning upon
this is winning upon maybe even two
pawns cuz these two things are attacked
this is nice so now I'm up two pawns I
have a pass C pawn explosive you have to
be a little bit careful
okay I just plunder the pawn back but he
didn't take it there are ops of Clare
bishops this should be winning
my king wants to be on c3 and then I can
start pushing them throw in a check
start pre moving and the strategy here
in when it comes to pushing pawns white
wants to push the pawns along the light
squares so black can't set up a blockade
so the next move is c6 and then I'll
just work the pawns down to the end of
the board unless he sacks and that's
winning okay so this should be an easy
win
ooh I have a funny idea okay I'm gonna
try and mate him with moving my king
let's see if this is gonna work now he's
not falling for anything well let's play
this
where's mate looking for a mate maybe
hopefully h6
okay this is good enough
this is really bad technique but I am
winning I want to meet him with the
final move being a key move not sure if
that's possible to set up probably not I
have to be careful about lag
Oh No No why did I drop my queen no that
was really bad that was really really
bad I got way too careless I was just
trying to flag him I had so much time to
had two full seconds
Oh queen bee five so bad I was having
like flashbacks so this was a Karpov
Judit Polgar pretty sure it was Carl
hugged you the Pulgar wait I'm doing a
Google search Karpov
Judit Polgar are still mates yeah for
those of you who haven't seen this
before
quick side notes and I'm mainly showing
this to make myself feel better about
myself
we're gonna go to study and we're gonna
call this making myself feel better
about myself and the first chapter is
going to be this game so board
non-aligned Safari is weird
okay that's good enough so this is what
we call chess therapy when you have a
very disappointing game and then in
order to feel better about yourself you
look at someone else someone else's
disappointment basically let's just zoom
forward to the end Karpov was winning
he made the Queen and then Karpov
essentially does what I kind of did was
just throw the position away in one move
Queen half three and it still meets so
now I feel better about myself because
Karpov
if Karpov makes these mistakes it's okay
the world goes on doctor tournament I'm
in 14th place I stopped using Chrome
because it was too laggy and Safari is
not laggy at all now I'm on tilts but
I'm still above 2,300 okay it's lady
five he's playing some kind of hippo
maybe what is going on mm-hmm
maybe he's confused
this is very deep opening preparation
hey I won my prep was too good I was
texting a friend the other day because
we were like sharing prep I typed in
prep and then autocorrect is trolling me
and it changes prep to Oreo because it
thought I meant to type O's rather than
Peas let's beserk again let's play
knight c6 it's off online now e v e4
it's Knights kind of stuck okay this is
fun mmm do this I'm okay with trading
Queens also okay with pinning the
Knights
so we trade a lot but I like my
developments
let's castle go for a rookie Yates g5
maybe
I don't know let's play a five
make sure the bishops defended I want to
trade off this Bishop Bacchus it's a
good Bishop and play b6 defend this pawn
and then I'll go for infiltration one of
these squares looks nice
I'm saving the bishop just be 5 kind of
traps and Knights its way g5 first both
of those Knights are kind of getting
kicked around problem with b5 is you can
take and then Knight c3 maybe I'll have
before in the end I have to play chief
war and keep the H file closed
whoa ok Knight c3 is coming but this is
a nice outpost
I want to go for d5 before also I'm so
low on time
I forgot I desert no one reminded me
maybe I'll have some mating attack this
was actually getting interesting
mmm I wanted him to play Knight b6 still
hoping for Knight b6
the meantime I plan is c5 c4 oh I lost
upon but he didn't take it now the plan
is probably rook c8 whoa what is this
oh he wanted to play nine of six okay my
king is kind of safe these Knights
attacks to move much quicker
no I lost the rook no this is gonna end
badly
this is ending very badly
he doesn't know the bridge technique
oh man losing another game this is
really bad
no it's terrible Oh No
what what went wrong there oh I lost I
forgot about my time
there's a nice position and then I got a
long time and blundered a rook because I
creamed move rook c1 ouch
it's too late okay I'll take opening
recommendations what you want
okay Sicilian someone so Danish gambit
if you play z5 I'll play Danish gambit
nope never mind I'll play a pan off c6
okay so we have a pan off I'm taking and
then Queen b3 this is a very famous line
actually yeah I remember playing this I
take C 3 is not the move usually six is
a move the White has double pawns but I
have an open file oh the bridge
technique I should have shown that as a
matter of winning the game more easily
h2 is this it's probably not a threat
because I have Queen take B 7 let's play
this
it takes a lot of bravery for back to
Castle kingside age six is reasonable
its retreats now he can't Castle
kingside because I have bishop take age
six so maybe I'll gospel Queen side then
I'll play rook v1
hmm well that was probably a bad move
because his King is less safe than
Viking I can take this
the king on f1 it should be relatively
safe there
put the rook on g3
hmm
wait Knight f4 I forgot about that f4
okay but that's still okay I think a
little bit scary play this if Queen d3
King G - I'm actually threatening made
in one here wait
this is getting scarier I think this is
all okay
it's very sketchy
this is very very sketchy my King is so
fragile okay so you saw the maid in one
threat now I can probably take on g6 and
just win
so somehow I okay survived the worst of
it and this should be mate in a few
there we go he had Queen g1 but I could
have run away at h3 and g4 so any hope
to win the tournament 3622 still kind of
within range but I need to like berserk
and streak out he missed Maidan one he
did have Queen g1 but yeah I think
infinite flashes rights the king would
run to g4
there should be two
okay so for this game I have to remember
that I bezerk my desserts I'll play
quickly enough and okay we have some
sharp position now try an attack on the
queenside
he's playing well let's play this
he's playing well and he's playing
quickly
you have to play much quicker
at least I have to have open files on
the queenside
so my rooks are kind of in play and the
sacks and ponds maybe get the Queen to
f4
I've 35 seconds this is not a situation
I want to be in but what to do this
Patmos battery is actually very strong
now I have some tactical threats you
can't really challenge the battery
either or he can okay let's take now I
want to play g4 soon maybe
PTX on g4 I play rock take a seven
and stuff is happening this is a threat
this is an idea
he plays King d8 I just check and win
the rook so I think the position is
busted but I don't have much time
I mean rotate b7 also a threats
okay let's take
everything will be hanging take either
look let's take this rook
so now I'm up to rooks okay he just
resigns that was nice
so that was berserk berserk game when
three points for that I'm in 11th place
first place has 40 points so I'm 15
points out the first which is only three
wins away but he's probably gonna keep
winning games too so it won't be so easy
remind me to show the bridge after this
tournament
yeah it's Boozer can let's play
aggressively I'll show the bridge
technique if people remind me
the joys of the Budapest's he's actually
playing decently this rook is getting
kicked around but it's still a fun
position never mind
this is kind of annoying trade bishops
and plant the rook in d4 place e5 yeah
it's no locks controlling d4 or I'll
probably put the rook back on each six
and then go for d6
I'm threatening Queen take g3 that's
nice
wait a minute I have to be careful what
I take with this is hanging I'll play
rook b1 probably or not
just defend
I don't know what to do position feel
stuck but the knight on e5 probably and
okay White's gonna flag maybe go for
this
okay I am in seventh place 14 points on
the first about twenty minutes left I'm
gonna try to keep it up five point
victories are always nice what is my
repertoire I like to play aggressive
openings in blitz playing we check okay
strong player buzzer King is bizarre a
prisoner came back that's nice let's
play uptown off I think I played them in
the sign before wow I have a terrible
score against we took seven to one was
this
he's playing well play H 3 preventing
Bishop g4 d3 Bishop g5 put the rook on
d1
mmm let's take and play Queen B 1 and
then 94 to c5 okay Knight a 4 I guess
yeah he's playing very well
let's take and play Bishop before when a
rook
maybe rookie for and g4 okay it's
getting really messy now but I think
things are slightly solid things are
kind of scary too but what to do bring
the knight to e3 oh you took with Pond
was not expecting that
yeah this is looking really bad now it's
looking really bad no that was really
bad oh we took - good okay
oh I'm playing the guy in first place
maybe should not have desserts but it's
okay so this is a French variation of
two Knights attack
maybe Queenie too
okay I'm trying to be aggressive in
Castle queenside
well to be a little bit careful
it's Castle kingside change of plans
I'll take on e6 and plate position Lee
yes o8 well he play King f7 that was
nice and that's a guy in first place
okay that's a good sign so now I'm in
fifth place I really have to start
winning more games and he has to start
losing more games or keep losing more
games yeah that loss - we tick was not
preferable also that draw ages ago is
not preferable was this opening people
are playing
let's play this okay I'm trying to be
aggressive again and I blundered upon
but I have some kind of compensation
maybe you display this Bishop c4
yeah 9h five and night g3 well maybe
come or maybe not okay
yeah this is very uncomfortable because
he's playing strong moves and he's
playing quickly I don't really have
chances to do much its do this
I'll take and play g5 I guess or not
let's play rook like King bee it's first
I want to play g5 soon had to play rook
d7 to not allow Bishop f6 that's a good
move
or is it Wow he's playing so well but
I'm attacking efore
if king is kind of safe
so strong
wait a minute this is checkmate in one
move
yes yes okay that was nice I felt like I
was getting smashed that game until I
wasn't getting smashed like he was on
the verge of checkmating me and then as
a random maiden - okay
fourth place I'm eight points out of the
lead so that's just - bezerk away it's
buzzer key again and let's play a Grand
Prix someone was mentioning Grand Prix
earlier it's a nice aggressive opening
to play play for Bishop b3 my mouse was
being over enthusiastic what's going on
here - dial down the settings he wants
to play c4 so let's buy a 598 only move
ooh
well now he's losing a pond or in
Knights his choice he loses a pawn
let's play Bishop to b3 keep the knight
restricted always play king h1
the Queen wants to go to h3 and then
like g4 g5
and probably f5 somewhere in there if my
g7 Queen h6 okay now it's a matter of
meeting somehow on h7 yeah probably
Knight g5 Bishop to g5 f t g5 and then
all with my rook over at six weekends is
diagonal if F six probably f5 also
rookie G 1 2 G 3 might be even more
direct yeah that's probably simpler
let's start with start with this open
that file bring the other up to G 1
some 11 minutes left Oh freak Wiener
please resign he's not resigning okay
off to win the old-fashioned way
what am i doing I just want him to
resign okay there we go
okay third place I'm one game away from
tying the lead this is going to be close
okay staffer gambit I'm okay free pawn
let's take here and Bishop c5 castling
or Kia coming d6
okay this is what I want just short
position can play for a win he's playing
for a win - not the most comfortable
situation maybe I'll play Queen here
going for a Bishop f5 let's play this
Greek gift maybe great gift on the Queen
side do I go for it I go for it Yolo is
he gonna take he does take a queen a for
coming this is a double piece sacrifice
this better work really better work
it's very risky she's got some
counterplay and some time to think
it's whoo unexpected that looks really
bad though
looks just really bad okay at the very
least I'm winning back material and even
more I think I'll take on f2 and then
when the exchange and be up a few ponds
to
okay this is nice be nice if he just
resigned so I have time for a game or
two more
but a people are in fighting moods today
so I want to go for rookie to the
ultimate plan maybe Queen C for ideas
now Ricky choose the threats
Quincy one quincy for all win c3 okay
should actually be mates somehow yeah
there we go
oh not yet Oh in the Knights and win the
rook
and when the pond and then when the when
the Queen and then when the King there
we go
so I'm in still in third place two
points behind I'm on a streak this is
gonna be close
okay the the guy in first place has a
losing position beserk again he's was
working two that's great
Playa Stafford
okay now it's already winning or is it
yes it is okay
free queen
such a great opening
maybe g5g for let's take on d4 first and
then g4 should have time for like one
more game after this
so much pressure build up this is great
this is so great okay
I'm in first place what a miracle after
so many bumps in the road now it's still
not over I probably have to finish one
more game back over 2,300 there's two
people that could potentially catch me
one of them lost their streak which is
great okay someone just passed me
let's beserk and I can't use more than a
minute this game hey it's a sub thanks
for the sub please take on C - ooh
b7 singing okay
wait this is getting awkward maybe d4
next kicking the night this is getting
really awkward I'm playing really badly
actually but it's okay
Keep Calm 92 next just have to
neutralize things like b3
not the prettiest position let's play
king d - yeah this is actually really
ugly this is really ugly
this is looking really really bad
time-wise position-wise
trying to hold on
No
no this is really bad I'm not going to
win this tournament
no wait what no I wanted to play off
seven no well this is a really sad
finish
really hoping my opponent pulls the carp
off
ouch well that didn't count for
tournament points and I was passed by
eiuís tick so I finished in finish in
third place disappointing but that's
what happens
good tournaments ones topsy-turvy I was
a really low quality last game a lot of
low quality games which I apologize for
but I tried I feel like I had hope there
if I play f7 someone asking what pulling
your carp off means I guess they were in
here earlier pulling a Karpov is let's
go to study myself making myself feel
better about myself
this is pulling a Karpov Karpov against
you the Polgara 1998 about 20 years ago
Karpov played Queen f3 and stalemated it
was a rapid match well thanks guys for
sticking around I think what I'll do
because people were asking about the
bridge I'll just really quickly show the
bridge a gentle reminder about the
bridge ok
I like gentle reminders let's find the
game it's a game I lost I think there's
this one
okay so time for an endgame lesson when
it comes to a bridge in chess it's all
about it's all about shelter like if
it's raining then you want to hide under
a bridge in this case I'm continually
checking the King and it seems like the
King has no shelter like I think what he
eventually did was like go in front of
the pawn but then the pawn camp promotes
so the bridge technique is actually very
simple the move to play the king d5 move
to play as king b5 let's go to analysis
board King be fine and now this is a
bridge like the specific position the
bridge happens with rook to be four so
the rook is basically providing shelter
to the king which allows the pawn to
promotes that's it wasn't nothing like
too fancy but it's this is very common
in king endings I believe or at least in
rook pawn endings anyway hopefully some
people learned something okay um it's
late it's hard to talk when it's late I
think I'm gonna end it there do I miss
any other questions
psycho rocks hello looking for questions
Oh
also thanks to entity se for the twitch
sub yeah I'm gonna end it there thanks
guys for watching
I'll be back maybe in the future I'll be
on the broadcast tomorrow for a st.
Louis Chess Club people can check it out
at 3:30 p.m. Central Time good night